It was January 16th, 1895.
Two men arrived at Lili’uokalani’s door,
arrested her,
and led her to the room
where she would be imprisoned.
A group had recently seized power
and now confiscated her diaries,
ransacked her house,
claimed her lands, and hid her away.
Lili’uokalani was Hawaii’s queen.
And she ruled through one of the most
turbulent periods of its history.
75 years earlier, American missionaries
first arrived in Hawaii.
They quickly amassed power,
building businesses
and claiming arable land
that they transformed into plantations.
They worked closely with the ali’i,
or sacred Hawaiian nobility
closely linked to the Gods.
The ali’i appointed missionaries
to government roles
where they helped establish Hawaii
as a sovereign kingdom
with a constitutional monarchy.
But once certain business
opportunities emerged—
namely, the prospect of exporting sugar
to the US tariff-free—
some of their descendants
shifted positions.
They formed a political group
known as “the Missionary Party”
and began plotting to annex Hawaii,
bringing it under US control.
Lili’uokalani and her siblings were born
into an ali’i family.
In 1874, her brother, Kalākaua,
ascended the throne,
but thirteen years into his reign,
the emerging threat crystallized.
The Missionary Party called a meeting
where an all-white militia surrounded
and forced the king
to sign new legislation.
Later called the Bayonet Constitution,
it stripped Native Hawaiians
of their rights,
diminished the monarchy’s power,
and ceded control to this group
of white businessmen.
Four years later, King Kalākaua died,
heartbroken, Lili’uokalani said,
“by the base ingratitude of the very
persons whose fortunes he had made.”
Prepared to fight, she assumed the throne.
Despite death threats
and rumors of insurgency,
Queen Lili’uokalani was determined
to restore power to her people—
an estimated two thirds of whom
had lost their voting rights.
Flooded with requests for change,
she authored a new constitution.
But before she introduced it,
the so-called “Committee of Safety,”
a new organization that consisted
of many Missionary Party members,
hatched another plot.
Under the false pretense
that this new constitution
endangered American property and lives,
they staged a coup on January 17th, 1893.
More than 160 US Marines
marched to the palace,
where the “Committee of Safety”
removed Queen Lili’uokalani from office.
Thousands of Hawaiian people protested,
some wearing hat bands reading,
“Aloha ’Āina,” or “love of the nation.”
The alleged “Provisional Government”
declared Hawaii a Republic
the following year.
They proclaimed
that Hawaiians couldn’t vote
or be government employees without signing
a new “oath of allegiance.”
Many refused.
The following year,
some of Lili’uokalani’s supporters
attempted a counterrevolution.
The Republic responded brutally,
jailing hundreds
and sentencing six people to death.
In exchange for their release,
the Republic made Lili’uokalani
sign a document
that claimed to relinquish her throne,
and they imprisoned her in the palace.
Under constant guard, she composed songs
expressing her love for her people
and began making a patchwork quilt
that told the story of her life.
While she was only allowed news
that had been reviewed by her jailers,
her supporters often brought her bouquets
from the garden she’d dedicated to them,
wrapped in newspaper.
After 8 months, Lili’uokalani was placed
under house arrest.
As soon as it was lifted, she traveled
to Washington, D.C.
with Hawaiian nationalists
and over 20,000 signatures.
There they successfully convinced Congress
to halt the Republic’s annexation treaty.
But the following year,
the Spanish-American War began.
Seeing Hawaii
as a strategic military base,
President William McKinley declared
it a US territory on July 7th, 1898—
breaking international law and devastating
Queen Lili’uokalani and her people.
She spent the rest of her life petitioning
for the restoration of her lands,
Native Hawaiian rights,
and national liberation.
When she died in 1917,
these dreams were unrealized.
A member of the group that forced
Queen Lili’uokalani out of office
once declared, “If we are ever to have
peace and annexation
the first thing to do
is obliterate the past.”
They failed at this goal.
Queen Lili’uokalani left
a resilient legacy:
Her commitment to her land and people
never wavered
and many Hawaiians continue to fight
in her memory.
Speaking of Hawaii’s children,
Queen Lili’uokalani said,
“It is for them that I would give
the last drop of my blood.”